luno the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin if
you're just getting into crypto it's the perfect
place to start hey guys and welcome back to my
show as always it is powered by icon plus so a
really quick news announcement for you so korea's
largest mobile phone provider denial fintech
will actually support icx as payment method this
year and launch a prepaid crypto card with china's
union pay so really exciting there now this
is sponsored by blockbuy you can get up to 8.6
interest on your usdc and it is also um sponsored
by coinflip so i will leave a link you can get um
a discount code so i'll leave that scrolling at
the bottom in a minute now if you are watching on
youtube please don't forget to hit the like button
and hit subscribe because you never want to miss
any of these fantastic guests now let's jump
straight into this because joining me today is
the founder of the global alternative investment
firm skybridge capital and salt conference and he
worked famously as the white house communications
director under president trump in 2017 for just
11 days i'm sure you can guess who it is it
is anthony scaramucci how are you doing today
well at least you got the time right you know
some people say 10 days later and it hurts my
feelings so i appreciate you mentioning the
last day of course in the last days the one i
probably the most famous for this one where i got
fire summarily fired so how are you i'm good thank
you i'm good how are you doing thanks for joining
me no i'm i'm terrific uh it's a it's a big uh
it's big opportunity right now in the crypto space
obviously there's uh lots of things going on and
uh lots of institutions are joining so uh i'm
super excited about that yeah it's pretty insane
and i do want to jump into all of that but before
we do um i messaged you before the interview and i
asked you is anything off limits and you told
me no you told me no no nothing's off limits
of course now why would there be anything off
limits that's not fun i love it cool so before we
jump into bitcoin then um i do want to just jot
back to 2017. can you give us a brief overview
of what happened and why you would only um the
comms director for only 11 days not 10 but 11.
well well i'm well i i have to probably take
you back to 2016 then to apply context i was
i i was a lifetime republican party fundraiser
uh mr trump was running for office uh none of
us took it seriously i was working for jeb bush
jeb came out of the race mr trump recruited me
uh i made many colossal mistakes but my first one
was accepting his invitation to join his campaign
we then won the presidency which seemed very
unlikely on november the 8th election day 2016
but then further to complicate things he wins
and then he names me to his 16 person executive
transition team so i was one of 16 people
on his executive transition committee
picking the cabinet interviewing under secretaries
and so forth and then he offered me a job the
original job was to be in the networking area
of the white house which is called the liaison
department so the it's sort of like a global
liaison coordinator rice priebus and steve bannon
two of my nemesis they didn't want me in that
job i didn't realize at the time how cutthroat
i thought wall street was cutthroat layla until i
got to washington i tell my buddies on wall street
i want you to imagine the worst person that you've
ever met on wall street that is the best person in
washington i mean we're a bunch of babies on wall
street compared to these people and so when they
went to cut my throat i got myself in a little
bit of a bind i let my pride get the better of me
i went to mr trump then president trump and said
these are two bad guys if you want to get rid of
them uh invite me back and i'll come and do
that and so he invited me in six months later
to be the coms director i was ill-suited for
that job even though i can present on television
i don't really have communications experience in
dc should have never taken that job but i took it
and then the fight started we had a
shootout at the okay corral between
me and reince priebus and steve bannon i said
something really funny uh but very important
well i don't want to say it on your show i mean
you guys can google it but i said something about
steve bannon and something that he was capable of
doing to himself anatomically which if you know
anything about steve bannon and his girth and the
fact that he doesn't do hot yoga uh you know he
probably couldn't do what i said uh and a result
of which the report reporter recorded that and
reported it on cnn john kelly the chief of staff
fired me for those remarks deservedly so uh and so
i think i made those remarks on day eight i think
i was fired on day 11 and so my what's the lesson
there is take accountability for your mistakes i
made a mistake i got fired never blamed anybody
for it and you know was also trying to be helpful
to the administration and the republican party
after my firing no no villains there no victims
i take total responsibility for my firing but
prior to those 11 days and for the last 33 years
less those 11 days i've been a money manager an
investment manager since i left law school
i started at goldman sachs i built a company
after i left goldman sold it
successfully and then started skybridge
16 short years ago and so that's really
what i've been doing for most of my life so
when they're trying to cancel you this is a
learning lesson for people that watch your show
they're trying to cancel you if you're an
entrepreneur it's very hard to get cancelled
because they fired me i dusted myself off
and went back to work at my own company
yeah council culture is rife right now um i can
even i can even tell you it's kind of rife within
the bitcoin community i had some cancelling of
myself yesterday it was it was quite the learning
curve who's trying to cancel you leia the ceo
was one bitcoin he canceled me yesterday so we'll
we'll just get that one out there maybe he'll
get over it we're in a rough we're in a rough
environment i don't take myself that seriously
uh here's my thanos cup in case you need somebody
to see that i mean why take yourself
that seriously and just remember
in the immortal wars of mel brooks the
95 year old american comedian relax
none of us are getting out of here alive
so try not to take things too seriously
no i totally agree with you um but speaking
of not taking yourself too seriously that
is something that uh good old donald trump never
did so he's a bit of a controversial character so
i do want to get into bitcoin but before we do
i do want to get like a brief understanding of
what he's like to work with because i watched
some interviews and you sort of played off this
character that's and that's not empathetic but at
the same time is deeply sensitive um to criticism
and ridicule so what kind of character is
he like you know i it's not personal my uh
my decision to break away from mr trump
and my decision not to back him in the
2020 election really not personal it's
an evaluation so let me just put it to
you this way let's say the two of us were on
the board of a publicly traded company either
in the uk or the united states we had to pick a
ceo we had selection criteria but unfortunately
we're only down to two choices and so we can only
pick these two people to be the ceo of our company
uh and we chose donald trump and then donald
trump had several years where he was operating
as ceo and he was manifesting himself in the
way that he did through his twitter account
the generosity of his rhetoric the insanity of
his hiring and firing process uh then you and i
would have to say as responsible board members
this is not uh good this is ill-suited to be
uh that ceo and then of course once again you only
have two choices so you have to choose between
the existing ceo i think is an object failure or
potentially somebody else and so you could also
be a failure possibly but i don't think so
i think he's doing a pretty good job i mean
yeah he's six weeks into it he's uh he's
a calm guy i'm sorry bomb syria already
he bombed syria already yeah you know
the in the united states whether people
like this or not uh is going to probably protect
its interests militarily around the world now
people can like that or dislike it but it's a
fairly bipartisan thing whether it's barack obama
more drone strikes in the first three years than
the bush administration's eight years uh whether
it's a left-leaning political administration
or right-leaning political organization
it's likely going to protect its
interests militarily overseas
irrespective you could like or dislike that
i'm just being observant about that uh if you
want my opinion about it i'm happy to share it
but that's really uh uh something that's gonna
happen that's an axiomatic fact of uh american
pop foreign policy whether people like that or not
but uh listen he's not donald trump and so
he's not offering this insanity on twitter
i think john kelly uh the gentleman that fired
me who i developed a very close relationship to
uh says it better than anybody and i'll quote from
him you don't realize how crazy donald trump is
until you're inside that one degree orbit of his
space once you're inside that space and you're
operating alongside of him you're like okay wait
a minute this guy's ill-suited to be president
he doesn't have the personality makeup or the
integrity or the bandwidth towards things like uh
empathy emotion and things like that to really be
the president so i made a mistake we move on but
you're asking me about him i'll tell you about him
he's a very complex wounded guy uh he's remarkably
insecure uh i guess i didn't see that when he
was in his area of competence which is being
a rock on tour a radio television reality host
but when he was put in the position of the head
of state of the world's most powerful military
and one of the world's most powerful economies
you got to see the manifestation of his full-blown
insecurity and so he couldn't handle people around
him that may have had expertise and or opinion
that was more sophisticated than his he tried to
steamroll those people or in the immortal words of
general mcmaster who served as his second national
security adviser he always was counter-intuitive
which was a way of saying i'm too insecure to hear
your opinion so i'm going to steamroll you so
very ineffective as a leader failed the country
13 million jobs lost during his four-year term
he made the country sicker he mishandled and
malpracticed on the pandemic we had 670 deaths per
million in the united states over the last year
compared to a place like south korea where
there were only 20 million sorry only 20 deaths
per million in south korea so we did 30 times
worse than a country like south korea due to
mismanagement of covet 19. uh he's an abject liar
34 000 lies were told during that period of time
he weakened our alliances not only the alliance
with the uk but i would say just about every
alliance that we built since the end of the world
war war ii he praised despots and dictators and
people that subject their populations to a lack of
freedom and he denigrated democratic leaders so i
think all in all uh i'm relieved to see him go and
i'll be around to make sure he doesn't come back
wow some really strong opinions um i have some
i think i'm holding back you know i haven't had
my coffee yet you know i'm i'm drinking hot
and cold that's you holding back yeah but i
think i'm holding back a little bit you know i
have a tendency to be fairly shy and reserved
so i'm just holding okay while holding back
here if we had more time i'd debate this with
you because i think it's a pretty interesting
one but i want to just kind of move a little bit
let's have the debate so it's apparently you
like him uh have you ever met him no it's not
that i like him i'm just less of a fan of biden
that's all like i'm i'm less of a fan of him
you're saying that uh uh president
i understand that the lessons
you got to do more homework interview more
people yeah you got to interview more people
that were in mr trump's inner circle so
that you could see his full-blown psychosis
and you can see his full-blown lack of empathy his
full-blown incapability of making good decisions
his lack of executive management and functioning
skills and the fact that he's a sociopath uh
whatever you think of uh president biden he's
not a sociopath and so i think uh you know
i'm interested in making money and taking care
of my family and protecting the people i love
i would prefer not to have a sociopath uh
sitting on top of the world's most powerful
military so no i'd be very happy to have that i
got you you i would love to have it with anybody
thank god 81 million people in the united states
agree with me and by the way uh you know despite
what i'm saying mr trump almost won that election
it was only a 71 000 vote differential among those
battleground states i'd love to debate it with you
but i cannot because i know we have a time cap on
this and i do want to talk about bitcoin because
that's the most interesting thing right now
at the moment trump is old news um right so okay
kind of moving on from that biden um is gonna pump
one point um what is it nine trillion into uh
the us economy so we've seen a crazy amount of
money printing over the last year with the whole
pandemic so i just want to get your perspective
on that and how you think that's gonna affect the
us dollar and then we'll kind of move into bitcoin
well i think it's important to give a little
bit more of a historical allegory so that you
can understand why we're in bitcoin and also why
we're so bullish on bitcoin and i'm going to take
you back to 1944 to bretton woods new hampshire
and in 1944 as the world was beginning the process
of entering the post-world war ii era and what
to do with the industrial economy some of which
were damaged in the war uh the economists
leaders people from trade around the world
trade associations etc got to bretton woods and
made some decisions and what was clear whether
you were a liberal economist or a conservative
economist what was clear was that we wanted
something and we wanted a term that we never use
anymore layla it is a purchasing power parity
and so what the economist said if we want to
promote global trade and peace and prosperity
and raise living standards the currencies the
global currencies have to be in a trading band
we can't let any of these industrial
nations manipulate their currencies i.e
cheapen their currencies on a relative basis
so that they can increase their exports and
so if you go back to bretton woods i think
it's very very important because over that
27 year period where bretton woods held
you had tremendous economic growth very
high prosperity numbers per capita and you had
rising living standards and a rising middle class
in 1971 the united states made a decision to break
from bretton woods and unclip the u.s dollar from
the gold standard and so just so everybody
understands that 35 an ounce for gold 1971
17 or so hundred dollars an ounce today
we crushed the us dollar we took it from
uh reasonably good purchasing power to a full
monetization and so let me just give that number
two u.s dollars two u.s dollars in 1971 have 100
of 20 21 dollars of purchasing power so you know
we we crushed the u.s dollar during that period of
time china manipulated its currency as well which
helped them become a mercantilist expert economy
and in 2008 we flooded the system with u.s dollars
to prop up the system after the global
financial crisis so satoshi nakamoto
or those people that are known as hitachi nakamoto
refined digital currencies there were several
digital currencies but they they got it almost
perfectly right with bitcoin and they sent it
into the marketplace they developed a white paper
which i recommend to everybody that they read
and he basically explained if we don't get back to
some kind of standardized currency for the world
we are jeopardizing living standards around the
world and that is true in the uk and in the united
states so after the introduction of bitcoin 12
years later the united states has pumped and
devalued its dollar but so has the british central
bank and so had the european central bank and
there has been global central banking coordination
to monetize debt and to flow tremendous amounts
of dollar production or currency production around
the world that helps rich people it hurts poor
and middle-class people and it's manifested itself
in nationalism it's manifested itself in populism
and it's led to the rise of political leaders
failed political leaders i might say but the
rise of them like donald trump and so this time
around with the pandemic because we have weak
political leadership in the west and no one wants
to develop an industrial policy a manufacturing
policy an education policy they just want to be
solely reliant on monetary policy we're producing
more dollars to try to solve this problem in the
last six months the volume of money supply in the
united states is up 26 percent so i just want
to stop and have everybody take a look at that
we have 26 percent more dollars produced in the
last six months than we had in the prior 244 years
if the stimulus that you referenced earlier
goes through the 1.9 trillion dollar stimulus
we will have 40 percent that's another 14 increase
in dollar volume you'll have 40 percent so where
is it going to show up it's going to show up in
asset prices expense of real estate collectibles
uh things like that but where it's not showing
up is in wages it's not showing up in middle and
lower middle income uh real income and so can
you talk can you can you talk more just about
that point because because i actually was talking
about the other day and i sort of said i i think
you know a healthier way to stimulate an economy
is to lower taxes rather than and print more money
and somebody had mentioned if you print more money
then how will people you know well if you lower
taxes people don't have money to pay basically
so what what i'm saying is if you're listening
you could you could expand the earned income tax
credit the ebit and so what could happen is at a
certain number you're making money in in your job
where you're not paying any taxes so could that
be 50 70 80 dollars and all of a sudden you're
increasing the living standards for the bottom
part of the pie yes but i think that the point
that someone was probably pushing back on you with
is with 27 million people out of work born from
the pandemic if they're not making any money
doing that doesn't really help them because
you know but like you said yeah like you said
printing money doesn't exactly create jobs for
the poor no you know you wouldn't if you if you
were really thinking about a way to help the poor
uh you would have to have at the intersection the
united states and the uk have been at its
best when there's an intersection between
public spending and the private sector economy
that happened after world war two as an example in
the u.s 16 million people service men and women
accepted the gi bill so they either got money
to buy a form they got money to participate in a
liberal arts education or an engineering education
at our nation's colleges and it laid the
groundwork for a very burgeoning middle class
we're doing none of that our bridges roads
and tunnels are in decay our airports are
in decay they look like third world country our
k through 12 educational system is very uneven
if you live in a good zip code in
the united states in an affluent area
you can get a good public school education if
you live in a inner city or with a poor tax base
around the school forget it the kids get passed
from grade to grade and they have no real skills
of anything they have remedial math and remedial
reading skills and so this is a downward shifting
the intelligence of the society and it's making
it harder for those people to get high wage
paying jobs so you're in a difficult situation
and so it does dovetail into bitcoin because
that white paper which was a brilliant piece
is basically suggesting that if you can scale
a decentralized monetary network you will put
to rest the policy whimsy of politicians and so
you know obviously what is the opposite of a
central bank a decentralized network and so
that network is scaling uh there's a hundred
plus million users today for bitcoin by 2025
there could be a billion users and if we're right
at skybridge capital if our economic team is right
michael saylor is right and others what you will
see is a full-blown decentralized monetary network
and in many ways that will help the world not hurt
the world the central bankers are threatened by it
right now but if they really study it they'll
recognize going back to a bretton woods like
construct is better for the world there's more
fairness if we have purchasing power parity
and governmental policy makers or politicians
in their respective states are not trying to
manipulate the manufacturing and export game
to benefit them and so hopefully that can
happen uh it's happening uh whether people
are gonna jump in i'm gonna jump in though
i i just want to go back though because like when
did you when did you first hear about bitcoin and
what was it about bitcoin as opposed to the other
cryptocurrencies you know like if for example
that made you think yeah i want to dedicate an
entire fund to that i kind of want to like if
you can bullet point maybe like the three or four
biggest things other than decentralization that
really kind of made sense to you so uh introduced
to bitcoin in 2013 by 2014 it's 400 a coin i'm an
institutionalist i know i can't sell that product
to my clients because it's not fully scaled
so bitcoin needed three things to have happen for
us to get involved one it had to continue to adopt
on the scale of metcalfe's law and grow
the network exponentially it has done that
two it needed to be regulated or taxed in
the united states it's taxed as an intangible
it's not yet completely regulated but that process
is happening i.e there's an etf in canada are now
two etfs in canada i expect by the end of this
year there'll be an american etf approved by
the sec and then the third thing which was
super important for skybridge was storage
you and i both know about the tragedy of
people losing their coins on their phones
laptops sim cards etc skybridge capital
has a half a billion dollars in bitcoin
uh we have it stored at fidelity in their digital
asset space it's ring fenced in cold storage so
it's off the grid and it's protected by fidelity
their team their balance sheet as well as a
an insurance layer from lawyers of
london so if you're going to have
institutional investments in bitcoin uh you're
going to need that type of protection why that
versus the others this is just our opinion bitcoin
is the big dog bitcoin originated 12 years ago
there's been 8 300 crypto competitors to
bitcoin that bitcoin has slayed you tell me
because i'm just guessing at current market
prices it's roughly 80 percent of the market share
of crypto assets that's out there and so
that's evidence to us that it has defeated
the other competitors in the space it's
the big kahuna in the space and since we're
institutionalists and we're going to have a hard
enough time migrating people to crypto in general
let's start with the biggest one
and let's stay on that for a while
perhaps it'll invite me back in
a few years and we'll have other
cryptocurrencies in our funds or maybe we'll have
funds specific to those other cryptocurrencies i
don't know but right now we're going to just
stick with uh bitcoin so with all of that in
mind then um you know there's this kind of
big rivalry between gold and bitcoin and a
lot of people say that bitcoin is gold 2.0 so i'd
really like your opinion given your background
why you think people like warren buffett and
peter schiff just can't get on board with it
well it has to do with fud right you know the
term fear uncertainty and doubt so we have fud
and then we have fuddy duddies and so what peter
schiff and warren buffett represent in that space
are fuddy duddies it's hard for me to quibble
with warren buffett because he's one of the
greatest investors ever at age 90 however
he's looking at the world a certain way
and that certain way has made him successful so
far be it for me to be critical of him however
i'll take your listeners and viewers back to a
seminal buffett story in 1999 i was present at the
sun valley uh allen and company media conference
a gentleman by the name of jeff bezos was making
a presentation related to amazon and he was
explaining that he was not going to focus on
earnings he was going to borrow and spend money
to scale his network so that he could become the
internet seller of all things that was in 1999
mr buffett said okay that sounds great i'm not
a buyer i don't believe in your story why don't
you believe in my story well i can't tangibly
price it in net present value of a discounting
stream of earnings because you're not going to
be making any money for 10 years and mr bezos said
well i don't want to make any money for 10 years
because i want to expand and grow the footprint
mr buffett said no uh who's been a better capital
allocator in the last 20 years mr bezos or
mr buffett and so we know that it's mr bezos
and we know that a ten thousand dollar
investment in amazon in its initial public
offering in may may 15 of 1997 is now worth 21
million one hundred and forty thousand dollars
and so so the point being is you can miss things
as an investor and still be a very successful
investor legendary in mr buffett's case um as it
relates to peter schiff he's stuck on gold that's
part of his business i like peter but i think
that they are intellectually not willing to accept
where the world is going and the world is going
digital and people of your generation frankly
are more comfortable in the digital world than
people that were burning born in the 1930s 40s
or 50s or even perhaps the 60s so as the world
is changing certain things are going to be more
valuable than others and i think they're missing
this because they are fuddy-duddies and they're
not willing to uh be neurally plastic
and adapt themselves to the new world
yeah i think when somebody makes a fortune a
certain way they kind of like have that blueprint
um and i think it can be so hard to adapt
and sort of see something different um i mean
i respect it but i i disagree with it in this
case this is something that's very obvious to
me and it's something that people should if
they're listening buy a small amount of it
uh don't buy enough of it where it could ruin
your living standard but buy enough of it where
uh you have a toll hold in it you'll learn more
about it and you'll be recognizing that you
don't own enough of it that's michael saylor's
line the first bitcoin is the hardest to buy
but once you own it you're like okay i don't own
enough of it i have to figure out a way to own
more but that is so true but i don't know anybody
that doesn't agree every single person always
hesitates before buying the first and then they
just they have to buy more but you said on cnbc
um that you think bitcoin could get to 100k this
year so i want to get your thoughts on that and
also um given the amount of institutional um
interest and institutional money just flowing in
how long really do you sort of see this bull
market going and how high if you look at other
halving cycles of course this having cycle uh
completed last may you probably have another 24
so months related this halving cycle and usually
that's when you get the upside swings in bitcoin
uh but you have something new happening right now
because of the amount of users we're in the 100
million plus user zone and it's it's edging into a
trillion dollars in terms of its market cap it got
there a week or two ago it's receded from that
uh you're now scaled it is now is important for
institutional investors take a look some of the
institutions i've talked to have said well if i'm
not long bitcoin i'm effectively short it because
it'll be part of the index and i better make sure
that i i've got some of it if i'm going to be
compared to it and so that supply demand imbalance
i think will push bitcoin through a hundred
thousand dollars by the end of the year remember
bitcoin went from last march to three thousand
dollars a coin four thousand dollars a coin
to forty eight thousand dollars a coin so it's
not that big of a move when you think about
the fact that three million coins have been lost
there are two-ish million coins left to be mined
and so let me put this uh supply demand balance
and stork numbers there are 46 million global
millionaires 46 million there are probably only
17 or so million bitcoins available you don't
even have enough bitcoin for each millionaire in
our society to own one coin and so if you put it
in that context you can see that there's going to
be heavy supply demand imbalances a fairly scarce
asset it's a trusted asset now from a value
transfer perspective because these cryptographs
over that network okay is what people are looking
for in terms of the certainty of value transfer
and so it's decentralized you can you can
take it outside of the banking industry
you can take it outside of the auspices of all of
that onerous regulation it becomes very compelling
and uh you know i i'm optimistic now having said
that i said a hundred thousand by a year-end
the fuddy-duddies i was talking to were
like whoa uh but then when you go on twitter
i'm getting yelled at by people yeah that's
consulting i'm not i'm not bullish enough so
yeah that's very concerning it's somewhere
i'm somewhere in the middle we'll get it right
yeah for sure just lastly because i know we all
pushed for time unfortunately but um tim draper
he said that he believes netflix could be the
next um major company institution to add bitcoin
to their balance sheet so i wondered who you
thought would be the next institution to do this
um say it one more time because
i i lost you there for a second
drake draper is bullish on bitcoin yep yeah but
but he said netflix would be the next institution
the next company to add bitcoin to their balance
sheet so i'm wondering who you think is next
amazon apple it's a good question i'm not i'm
not sure um you know somebody asked me point
blank of i thought apple would add bitcoin to its
balance sheet i said yes now that i'm going to be
50 50. it's either going to be yes or no but
the reason i'm suggesting apple is that they
want to be in the wallet business they've got a
credit card now they're making it easy for you
to use your credit cards over this phone and the
notion that if they start to own and understand
bitcoin and we eventually get which i predict
we will a digital dollar and a digital yuan
uh you have the uh you could have bitcoin sitting
on your phone alongside of a digital dollar a
digital yuan even your digital share of walmart if
you will um and so you know you you're you're in
this situation where um uh apple will likely be
somebody that owns or starts to own bitcoin but
but again i don't have any information related
to that um i don't i i could see why he's saying
netflix they've got a lot of cash on their balance
sheet um they're cutting edge enough to look at
it they've made some changes to their business
model several times and so they're adaptive people
uh take a look at square take a look
at what jack dorsey is doing there
um bitcoin is going to be a part of the future
whether peter schiff likes it or not or people
that don't bitcoin deniers are going to be
disappointed i'm a bitcoin investor i was once a
bitcoin skeptic that has become a bitcoin investor
i'm not a bitcoin evangelist i think that you know
it's not like jesus and moses got together and
had a baby and it happened to be bitcoin i'm not
a bitcoin evangelist right see the strengths
and weaknesses of bitcoin uh but i recognize
that this is a big part of our future and if we're
right it could have exponential growth from here
that i want to take advantage of for myself
and my customers i want to thank you so much
for coming on um it's been so interesting i do
have so many more questions i want to ask you so
much appreciate it congratulations on your
show be well thank you so much take care bye